the UN Secretary General has warned that
artificial intelligence is being used to
spread disinformation and hate Antonio
guterres says while technological
advancement has been used for some good
the risks posed by AI threatens
democracy and human rights or diplomatic
editor James Bays reports from New York
the Secretary General was speaking at
the launch of a new UN policy on
disinformation now ai is part of that
things like deep fakes manipulated video
and images and as he spoke to reporters
he gave his sternest warning yet about
the challenges facing the world as a
result of artificial intelligence
the scientists and experts have called
on the World to act
declaring Ai and existential threat to
humanity
on a bar with the risk of nuclear Wars
the Secretary General also announced
that he's urgently constituted a
scientific Advisory Board to look at the
problems of AI and he'll announce the
names of that board with experts from
across the U.N in the coming days he's
supportive of recent announcements made
by the British government that there
should be a global Summit held by the UK
later this year to discuss the issue of
AI and he also supports a plan again
from the British prime minister Rishi
sunak that there should be a UN agency
perhaps like the iaea that deals with
atomic energy specifically to deal with
artificial intelligence James Bay's Al
Jazeera of the United Nations
Robert Sparrow is Professor of
philosophy at Monash University and has
published extensively on the ethics of
AI and robots he joins us now from
Melbourne welcome to the program so uh
to what extent do you think there are
real and current dangers posed by AI
I think there are large changes posed by
AI as it is now uh in particular its
challenge to democratic uh processes and
elections
um as was just mentioned AI has
tremendous capacity to spew out uh
misinformation and disinformation
tailored to individual users in ways
that can topple governments shape
elections it has military applications
that worry me as well is it just fantasy
though to imagine that AI even now or in
the future can never be regulated or
governed by any kind of international
agreements
look AI relies heavily on standards and
intellectual property you could pull the
plug on a lot of this industry uh by
insisting that you couldn't hold patents
and trade secrets in it uh it relies
very much on standards so regulation
makes technology possible and so it
offers also an opportunity to control uh
technology this is going to be a global
issue and so that does create some
difficulties but I don't think that we
should give up just because it requires
a certain amount of expertise to
understand how the technology works at
some level we all have choices in this
matter is regulation there actually
enforceable across borders
I don't think any one agency is going to
be able to completely control uh AI I
think we are looking for a culture
change particularly in engineering and
computer science but also across
government and Civil Society uh and uh I
think it's going to be an ongoing
um you know struggle as it were but I
don't think it's something we should
have abandoned all hope of uh just
because we expect it to be difficult and
what if this idea that AI is going to
destroy humanity and the like is that
largely Hysteria
it's pretty hard Outsiders to
have an informed opinion on that topic
because you can find people with phds
from MIT and Stanford saying there is an
existential risk from Ai and you can
find people who seem equally well
qualified uh saying there isn't
um the case for regulation here doesn't
rest on the idea that it's an
existential threat if this really is a
world shaping technology as people often
advertise it to be then everyone in the
world has a right to have a say about it
I can't see any of the existing machines
waking up and taking over but I can
certainly
name people who think there is that risk
Robert Sparrow we very much appreciate
your time thank you
thank you